[Music]
no I don't want it I want it peanut
butter is a savory thing Thai people
know about that honey what is wrong with
you how fun is that am i pregnant like
something sweet its sour and vinegary
it's gross I like how crisp it is I also
like that my mind cannot figure out what
I'm eating the pickles really tart
pickle and peanut butter book very
strong flavors so they fight each other
so hard for the dominant flavor in your
mouth I love hot cheetos mellow pudding
but yeah chili pudding is a thing chili
and chocolate yeah Gillian chocolates so
good it's like a spicy sweet garbage
smell oh that's nice it's not terrible
oh god it's weird though it's like sweet
on the outside and then crunchy and
spicy in the middle if marijuana didn't
exist the snack could never come to be
oh that's what monster created this oh
it's like something you see on the side
of the beach it's so salty I'm so sad
right now
it tastes like potato salad but the
banana it's like I'm swallowing blue
slimy nasty he's like I ate a moldy
crown you know it's good the textures
are so similar at some point it's like
is it banana is it mayonnaise is it a
nightmare this is even happening
this one's a STONER ran out of cereal it
was like whoa what's the difference the
goldfish look like they're in their
natural habitat for the first time
actually it's like a salty cheese it's
weird it's the first food we're like the
only taste I can describe is funny
my mouth is super dry now I think I like
goldfish like this better than by
themselves
like Hershey's Kisses it does but then
I'm very terrified about the underneath
part mixed with it amazing I thought the
pizza screaming like taste me taste me
well now I don't like it but half of me
still likes it this is awesome the
marinara sauce killed it for me the
Nutella sticks to the roof of your mouth
making the cheese stick to the roof of
your mouth so you're stuck with just a
bread on the bottom you gotta tell it
all over you that's the woman's dream
[Music]